quant au problème de culture j'ai fait
décidé que le fameux 1% pour la culture
serait mis à exécution dans les deux ans
qui viennent le budget à tiendra cette
fois ci 75 % 0 75% de 1% sera donc
atteint l'année prochaine
j'ai demander la réintroduction et
monsieur le ministre la culture avec moi
de la culture dans le plan dont elle
était absente
la généralisation du 1 % des
constructions publiques appliqué
aujourd'hui à l'éducation nationale quel
champ ouvert aussi aux artistes
créateurs de toutes les disciplines qui
vont avoir des commandes
j'ai pris en compte bien entendu le
développement du musée d'orsay
un nouveau président directeur général a
été désigné le précédent ayant quitté
son poste le développement de la ville
est le développement de la décence qui
seront des oeuvres qui je l'espère
marqueront l'esthétique moderne en même
temps que l'urbanisme
j'ai également pris la décision mesdames
et messieurs sans vouloir d obliger
personne de rendre le louvre à sa
destination et de ce fait j'ai demandé
au premier ministre de prévoir
l'installation et la construction du
ministère des finances dans des lieux
aussi noble qu'il le mérite
le sans qu'il y ait de confusion
excessive entre l'état de fonctionnaires
de cette noble maison et les objets
d'art il convient de montrer au public
une première biennale nord-sud sera
inauguré en 1983 à la fois beau bourg et
au grand palais nous célébrerons le
bicentenaire de la révolution en 1989 il
faut préparer cela dès maintenant
nous bâtirons une cité internationale de
la musique
nous allons mettre en pratique la
fondation européenne pour la culture ce
qui nécessitera aussi certaines
constructions ainsi que la maison pour
l'islam et j'ai engagé les premières
conversations pour que place soit faite
à la france pour une exposition
universelle en 1989 deuxième centenaire
de notre première révolution
le premier centenaire ayant été célébré
par une exposition universelle dont il
nous reste beaucoup de choses et
notamment la tour eiffel et au travers
de cette exposition universelle
là aussi et bien sûr le chantier ouvert
à l'imagination à l' ouvrage d'art à
l'artisanat aux humbles et grands
métiers à tout ce qui permet à la france
de ses sièges de se sentir plus jeune
songez qu'en 1878 je ne crois pas me
tromper
une exposition universelle eu lieu qui
marqua le redressement de la france
sept ans après la commune la défaite est
alors que plusieurs milliards or devait
être payé à la prusse et nous ne serions
pas capables dans la situation où nous
sommes de marquer notre choix de
l'avenir chez notre confiance dans le
pays par la mise en oeuvre de cette
grande entreprise jacques chirac parlait
donc cohabitation hier soir françois
mitterrand a répondu continuité ce matin
le chef de l'état a inauguré le musée du
neuvième siècle dans l'ancienne gare
d'orsay ce musée c'est le résultat du
travail de trois présidents de la
république c'est une remarque du chef de
l'état un bel exemple de continuité
esthétique at il dit mais la continuité
se déroule aussi sur bien d'autres
domaines
cela a été conçu l épreuve de monsieur
pompidou
c'était une heureuse conception que de
vouloir utiliser cette gare que j'ai
connu moi même lorsque j'étais étudiant
car débarquant d'angoulême c'est
toujours là que je vous disais c'était
un lieu vide abandonné plutôt que de se
lancer dans des constructions
hasardeuses
je pense que l'idée était très heureuse
d'utiliser cette gare comme on l'a fait
en suisse et monsieur giscard d'estaing
qui a mis au point le projet qui a fait
les premiers financements qui en a prévu
grosso modo la période et en 1981 nous
étions quand même moins content car les
gros oeuvre est à peine entamé les
crédits ne tue pas quand même suffisante
par rapport à l'ampleur du projet le
principal pour moi c'était de continuer
et j'ai continué ensuite c'était
d'adapter les crédits nous avons adopté
des crédits ensuite c'était de d'élargir
deux façons historiquement il fallait
peut-être bien préciser le point de
départ est le point d'arrivée et j'ai
repris tout simplement l'initiative
première 1848 50 1910 14 et puis quand
j'ai décidé la création du grand louvre
utilisation différente indispensable
pour le temps modernes du musée du
louvre comme devaient loger ici
précédemment une série d'administration
touchante à la direction du musée
naturellement le musée d'orsay a
retrouvé une place disponible dans
bellechasse le nom de neil lui a permis
de remplir son programme
voilà ma l'action mais cette action
nécessité que dans la ligne de ce qui
était fait deux fois avant moi c'est
donc sous trois présidents de la
république que le musée d'orsay aura été
créé c'est un bel exemple de continuité
esthétique vous allez vous demander
justement la continuité ne peut être que
culturel non non elle est la continuité
se déroule sur bien d'autres plans
chaque fois qu'il ya quelques intérêts
de la france les principaux qui sont en
cause
on les retrouve dans certains domaines
politique étrangère dans certains
domaines de politique de défense
on le retrouve aussi ailleurs bien
entendu dans certaines formes de
politique d'équipement mais j'en passe
et en tout cas très heureux que le musée
d'orsay soit la preuve on peut concevoir
à distance comment pourrait-on faire il
faut des années et des années
si lorsqu'on a construit la gallina city
de deux ans ce personnage est démis
rajeb du monde comment ne plus faire ici
il a fallu ce temps 8 ans 9 ans et cela
dépasse la durée d'un mandat de
président de la république et de loin à
la durée les gouvernements voilà
pourquoi je crois qu'on a agi sagement
le président de la république a visité
cet après midi l'exposition janus qui
préfigure ce que le sera le musée des
sciences et des techniques à la villette
auparavant le chef de l'état avait
inauguré en compagnie du ministre de la
culture la grande halle de la villette
entièrement restauré vingt mille mètres
carrés d'un bâtiment au vieux de 120 ans
qui a été réhabilité à des fins
culturelles
un exemple unique en son genre et qui
s'inscrivent dans une double optique la
sauvegarde du patrimoine industriel et
l'ouverture d'une politique culturelle
scènes ce grand de hal hébergera aussi
bien en effet le carrefour des
technologies que le salon international
de la musique ou bien encore les grands
jeux de l'été
c'était donc le 26 ou le 26 août 1789 la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen célébré aujourd'hui très
officiellement comme il se doit par le
président de la république lors de
l'inauguration à la défense de la
fondation de l'arche de la fraternité un
lieu symbolique où se réunissaient tous
ceux qui oeuvrent dans la lignée du
texte de 89 pour la défense des droits
de l'homme dans le monde florence bukiya
il fallut un mois de débats à
l'assemblée nationale constituante pour
adopter le 26 août 1789 la déclaration
de droits de l'homme et du citoyen deux
cents ans plus tard l'acte 2 du
bicentenaire de la révolution française
et dignement fêté avec comme point
d'orgue l'inauguration de la grande
arche de la défense
cette arche de la fraternité abritera la
fondation de cloud chez son ancien
ministre des relations extérieures
françois mitterrand a inauguré ce soir
cette sorte de tour eiffel du
bicentenaire a affirmé vous comme les
mainteneurs obstiné de la tradition qui
refusaient condamnent les violations des
droits de l'homme qu'il s'agisse du
racisme des dictateurs vivre de leurs
pouvoirs des terroristes preneurs
d'otages ou de la volonté de domination
d'un état sur un autre ne transigeait
pas sur le droit des peuples à disposer
d'eux mêmes projections à l'échelle du
monde et droit de lundi
du haut-nkam et par notre révolution et
soyez fiers de ce que la déclaration
universelle de 1948 s'inscrivent dans le
droit fil de la déclaration du 26 août
et transpose dans l'ordre international
les libertés fondamentales que définir
nos ancêtres
à l'endroit
le couronnement de ce jour d'exception
la soirée était placée sous le double
signe de la musique et de la fraternité
maxime le forestier jacques higelin
barbre hendrix manu dibango cheb khaled
et d'autres encore chante les droits de
l'homme en ce moment même sous la grande
arche de la défense
voilà nous pourrons
merci monsieur le président d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et puis nous
gardons donc mentaux c'est vrai qu'il ne
fait pas très frais alors cette première
question c'est à propos de l'origine du
projet il ya une vive polémique pas
complètement terminé d'ailleurs on a
employé des mots comme sacrilège on
avait dit à l'époque
est ce que vous n'avez pas eu un feu
dirait un petit vertige au moment du
choix final car cela vous engagez nous
aussi français pour des siècles
sans aucun doute
je ne me suis pas des cités comme cela
éléments
j'avais la conviction qu'il fallait que
nous
musée du lot car il s'agit de ça
de 20 lieux où l'on aimerait aller voir
les oeuvres admirable qui citron
et leurs moyens l'accès les commodités
la présentation des oeuvres ça ne
marchait pas alors comment faire
j'ai donc consulté les architectes qui
ont étudié
de multiples projets et celui de
monsieur paye mais apparaît comme le
plus rationnel le meilleur qui prétend
que plus beau oui mais c'est la décision
policiers non mais j'ai le temps
reconnaît par rapport à l'oeuvre du
temps construction passé cet ensemble
d'oeuvres maîtresse qui se trouve au
coeur de paris c'est un problème qui va
donner beaucoup de soucis ici je me suis
décidée c'est vraiment en conscience la
présidence de projets culturels dont
vous êtes le plus fier aujourd'hui
bon disons que j'ai fait après dilution
alors que ça vient de loin
longtemps avant du président la
république que je me disais ça va pas
cette cour napoléon nous sommes
ce soir avec ses arbres l'épreuve
c'est jp des parkings fou
la nuit je pense que
j'ai hésité à s'y promener noir tout ça
pour ce beau musée à côté ce beau musée
il fallait changer vous avez absolument
adapter
le temps modernes aux monuments anciens
voilà voilà ce que ça donne
le justement que je prends quand vous
avez dit oui à monsieur p vous aviez une
idée de son projet bien sûr on l'imaginé
mais est-ce que ça correspond à ce que
vous aimez je veux dire que
plusieurs grands architectes me
paraissait souhaitable et finalement si
j'ai arrêté mon choix sur paye
cette ce chinois américains c'est parce
que j'avais vu à washington et à boston
deux de ses oeuvres maîtresses m'amuser
en particulier vraiment c'était peu
admirable mais ça vous étiez c'est
l'homme de la situation
après une conversation je me suis rendu
compte que qu'il est l amoureux non
seulement
le louvre mais de l'histoire de la
france et que jamais le commettrez la
faute dirais même le crime
nuire à l'ensemble dans lequel nous
sommes loin il ya une tradition
présidentielle on peut dire ça de
laisser quelque chose à l'histoire je
parle
monsieur pompidou du président giscard
d'estaing ou avec le grand lot la dette
défense
l'opéra bastille alors bien sûr c'est
pour la france et pour la grandeur de la
force mais il n'y a pas une part de
prestige personnel
vous pouvez dire ce que vous venez
naturellement il pensait mais je crois
que seul président de la république
disposent du temps sept ans au moins
permettre d'en qui permette de décider
d'entreprendre et de mener à bien
souvent ils font plus de sept ans mais
dans notre élan s'il veut pas s'arrêter
mais le président est ce que vous
aimeriez qu'on parle du style mitterrand
je veux dire à travers les choix que le
dur est que vous avez on peut dégager
quelques grandes villes vous aimez les
très très beau les choses très épuré on
veut parler de style qu'on pourrait
opposer certains journaux l'ont fait ce
matin à votre personnalité pouvait plus
cacher moins transparents par exemple
ces pyramides à sion du jeune
mitterrand j'en serais flatté je lave
mes génies en a pas
car l'ensemble des grands projets relève
du choix du jury internationaux ou
nationaux
et si en effet
j'ai pris part à la décision et même si
j'ai pris la décision finale dans chaque
cas c'est aussi parce que j'avais un
certain goût pour les formes
géométriques pur mois quelques gigas
n'est déjà pas vrai de l'opéra bastille
mais il n'y avait pas de projets en
concurrence qui répondent avec des
finitions
en revanche je voyais ce qui se passe
avec la géode à la villette dont je suis
d'ailleurs pas l'auteur le voyez ce qui
se passe ici ni vous voyez marche du
future installation de la défense il
veut dire un arc de triomphe de plus
dans la grande perspective qui va
jusqu'à la terrasse de saint germain
cela correspond je crois que les formes
pures et simples me plaisent plus que
les autres c'est président vous êtes
sûrement interrogé plus que quiconque
sur le pouvoir et en voyant cela ce
matin avait pâti siens et d'autres
personnes pour visiter en sit in et
est-ce que c'est pas là la manifestation
la plus symbolique du
voir se dire ici dans cette zone on vous
parlait tout à l'heure le soir papa très
tranquille et bien moi je décide de
faire quelque chose
c'est pas ça le pouvoir
c'est une forme déterminante du pouvoir
et pour avoir des malades ou les sens
puisque j'étais étudiant à paris pour
avoir beaucoup circulé je me suis
beaucoup promené dans paris dans ma tête
c'est vrai tout moment je rebaptisé
pensez pas que j'en aurai l'occasion et
quand j'en ai l'occasion je n'ai pas
raté
oui parce que dans les livres d'histoire
qu'est ce qu'on va retenir est ce qu'on
va dire je ne sais pas il ya eu telle
loi sous le septennat ou quatorze années
du président mitterrand parce qu'une loi
ça peut se défaire mais tandis que là on
dire non mais une fois ça peut se
défaire dans l'ic ça ça bouge oui est-ce
que vous travaillez pour l'élu
d'histoire les choses il ya le fait que
nous sommes précisément au coeur de
l'histoire de france
puisque c'est à compter de pita côté que
se trouve la tour du fils d'auguste
retour de l'ours et là on peut le dire
le royaume s'est fait jacques lafrance
est fait
c'est autour d'eux de ce bâtiment là
c'est tout du louvre que philippe
auguste avec le show royal une marque et
qu'il y avait une unité du royaume et
tous les ans partait de là je pense
qu'ils se pressaient exaltante penser
qu'à la suite
le palais des tuileries qu aujourd'hui
détruit et qui a marqué à partir de
catherine de médicis du nom d'une
nouvelle série déconstruction intégrale
et puis tout ce qui a fait finalement
l'endroit où nous sommes c'est en effet
très exaltant pour l'esprit que d'y
ajouter même avec modestie parce que
tout je ne prétends pas être celui qui
décide de ce qui l esthétique en france
mais y avoir contribué
alors monsieur le président nous allons
maintenant sortir du cadre du grand
louvre ont regardé ensemble si vous
souhaitez pour nous intéresser je disais
tout à l'heure au septennat culturelle
alors le septennat culturel du président
mitterrand dès qu'un certain nombre de
grands projets dont certains comme celui
ci sont bien avancés alors parmi les
lampes des réalisations à la villette du
ministère des finances à bercy
l'opéra de la bastille la tête des
enfants nous avons parlé voici avec jan
cadieux la présentation de ses grand
talent
cette vue prestigieux sur paris les
visiteurs pour la découvrir à partir du
14 juillet 89 du toit de l'arche de la
défense la plus grande partie des
bureaux de large ont été vendus au privé
mais c'est dans les 35 étages de la
paroi sud que pierre méhaignerie qui s'y
installera les demies fonctionnaire du
ministère de l'équipement le 14 juillet
89 c'est aussi la date de l'ouverture de
l'opéra de la bastille dont les travaux
vont retrouver leur rythme normal après
le compromis passé entre le ministre de
l'économie et celui de la culture choix
de la transparence sur le quartier de la
bastille de la part de l'architecte
potes
les visiteurs apprécieront sans doute la
qualité des espaces
ici les galeries et les foyers et les
espaces aussi de la grande salle de 2700
places
l'inconnue demeure par contre pour la
deuxième salle ici que le gouvernement
souhaite vendre au privé comme les
ateliers de décors les retards
construction attributions auront
entraîné en tout cas quelque 200
millions de dépassement sur coup aussi
du même ordre à bercy où se poursuit les
travaux de construction du futur
ministère des finances plus de 5000
fonctionnaires gossip installé pressent
pour l'instant occupent les lieux
la direction générale des impôts
mobilier adapté bureaux ultramodernes et
surtout informatisé c'est la vitrine
attendu de la technologie française
notez aussi ce système de chariots
suspendu pour la transmission des
dossiers les fonctionnaires encore au
louvre en tout cas aimerait bien en
profiter où ça déconne profond d'après
les réponses que nous avons des gens
mais en fait nous avons fait que la
majorité des gens au vote que le
déménagement se fasse et en totalité le
plus rapidement possible
et puis ne vient plus de ses caprices
finalement qui font que c'est
constamment retardée que les gens sont à
7 dans l'incertitude qui boxe sont
angoissés finalement pour l'heure
edouard balladur se maintient au louvre
de l'identité du prochain ministre des
finances en tout cas dépend l'occupation
plus ou moins rapide de bercy et partant
la libération du palais du loup alors le
projet grand lourd comprend
l'agrandissement mais aussi la
rénovation de certaines parties de
l'actuel musée
or cela suppose que le ministre le
ministère des finances qui l'a tout près
bien d'un se déplacer mais alors est-ce
que vous considérez monsieur le
président que pour autant le chantier
est en panne
il a été retardé il a coûté plus cher
mais ce projet est inéluctable désormais
au point nous en sommes et je m'en
réjouis
c'est la marche de l'histoire on peut
pas les goûts on peut pas les comptes
et quand des millions de visiteurs
seront vendus par là cela s'imposera de
telle sorte que les cotisants barak
ministre additionne
gevo l'union c'est le président tourne à
l'être il ne faut pas et accélérer les
choses je veux dire ce que vous ne
pensez pas que le futur président de la
république devrait accélérer le départ
du ministère des finances qui occupe une
étude je le pense car l'oeuvre ne sera
complète qu'après cela et l'on peut déjà
imaginer ce que seront les cours de
l'actuel ministère réservé à de très
belles oeuvres de sculpture avec le
débouché sur le palais royal au travers
d'une admirable porte qui est la porte
qui chante mieux donc si vous étiez
président de la république
les acteurs biais des cieux sans aucun
doute bien alors que c'est la commission
dure monsieur présente question qui va
vous paraître l'aï mais certains se
demandent si ça coûte cher
s'il était vraiment prioritaire de faire
tout cela
ça coûte non pas comme d'autres le 10 1
milliards
mais une quinzaine de milliards répartis
sur 2 7 à 10 ans donc il faut découper
cela en tranches pour l'introduire dans
le budget
il faut savoir aussi ce qu'on ignore
trop souvent c'est que j'ai hérité de
plusieurs de ses projets parmi les plus
importants la villette
orsay et l'institut du monde arabe sont
des projets conçus par monsieur giscard
d'estaing que j'ai réalisé mais qui
était déjà décidées dans leur principe
mêmes dans leur future unité
architecturale
cela représente environ déjà 40% de ces
15 milliards j'y ai ajouté d'autres
grands projets vous les avez cité toute
valeur on va sélectionner six volets
pour la rapidité du discours
actuellement l'arche mais la défense
l'opéra bastille et leur look
je ne pense pas que ce soit trop cher
par rapport aux gains quand tireur à la
france et cela représentait aussi des
milliers d'emplois dans des métiers en
péril qui sont les métiers d'art je
crois que finalement sur un bénéfice
j'ajoute que cela devient rentable en
même temps ça lui vaut garde c il ya
chaque jour environ une moyenne de 13
mille visiteurs allant bien viendront
ici monsieur mitterrand et les vieilles
pierres parions de qualifier ainsi le
patrimoine de la france mais certains
disent au fond le président il n'aime
que créer des choses faire des grands
travaux il a un peu délaissé les églises
les cathédrales et s'est même dit
souvent su relier les tribunes chaque
soir actuellement le ce n'est pas vrai
les crédits attribués au patrimoine sont
passés sur la lys la thur précédente
de plus de 500 millions à plus de 800
millions
et on repart chez en effet avec le
ministre la culture sur la planche et
j'ai entrepris la restauration du
patrimoine au travers de la cathédrale
d'amiens de la cathédrale de reims de la
4e balle de bourges avec atriale de
porto de la 4e' dalle de strasbourg vous
vous souvenez sans doute de cette pièce
populaire à strasbourg enfin on a put
achevé ce qui avait été entrepris dans
cette belle cathédrale
ce ne sont que quelques exemples on a
créé quelques milles bibliothèque
on a rénové qu'une son musée de province
on s'arrête à mon récit et on a aussi
engagé des travaux nouveau
vous savez bien les meubles de la bande
dessinée le centre l'emblème de la
photographie à arles de la musique
a lyon ii les archives du travail
roubaix j'en passe vous pas être trop
long dans ma libération je dis
simplement que c'est une critique
injuste
assurément en raison de la modicité des
crédits bien que nous ayons avec jacques
landes doubler les sommes les crédits
naturel évidemment on peut pas tout
faire à la fois par exemple je le suis
longtemps plaints auprès du ministre
auprès du premier ministre de ce que
l'on n'ait pas fait ce qu'il fallait
faire pour le muséum d'histoire
naturelle
bon ça a été entrepris mais j'ai dû me
battre pendant au moins trois ans et
comment ça se passe dans ces cas là la
modernisation nécessaire de soutien va
commencer à cette époque mais il m'a
fallu aussi insister beaucoup pour
convaincre les prédécesseurs de monsieur
chirac
pour moi ce que je peux dire qu'on peut
pas tout faire à la fois alors forcément
quand on veut critiquer on peut toujours
relevé que ceci n'a pas été fait je le
concède qui ferait mieux et puis voilà
le problème
je suis en arrivant au terme de cet
entretien
est-ce que de profits de questions qui
dépassent un peu le cadre de
vous avez l'impression en lisant les
sondages jours que les pensées sont un
peu agacé
jouer avec leurs nerfs parce que vous
déclarez pas suffisamment tôt à leur
avis pour moi c'était une affaire on
n'est pas son sens du terme de vous dire
quand même un mot sur la conversation
principal que nous voulons obtenir ump
simplement pour dire que
je suis de ceux qui croient profondément
et ceux qui le croisent se retrouve dans
tous les camps 1 dans toutes les
formations politiques mais je suis de
ceux qui croient que une politique
culturelle est à la base de toute autre
politique qu'il faut que les français se
retrouvent dans leur histoire dans leur
art dans leur passé pour qu'ils sachent
mieux avoir l'ambition de leur avenir
c'est pourquoi j'ai beaucoup tenu à ce
que la culture apparaissent comme une
des actions principales
les gouvernements auxquels j'ai pu
dresser ils ont des conseils vous êtes
fini votre travail mais j'étais dans mes
de ce point de vue là je dis je n'ai pas
fini mon travail je vois où vous voulez
en venir
par rapport à ce que nous voyons puisque
nous sommes encore sur un chantier ce
que je peux dire c'est que spécialement
par rapport au grand louvre
le relais était bien pris l'habitude et
de ce fait monsieur léotard athermique
les retards qui s'annonçait soient
réduits admettre ce qui est la
continuité dans ces domaines a joui
alors vous voulez revenir à votre
question que je crois à fond premiers
jeux wii le suppose que vous l'avez
deviné maintenant pays
je ne sais pas si les français
s'impatiente
ce que je pense c'est qu'ils comprennent
très bien que je fasse mon métier de
président c'est pourquoi ils m'ont élu
il ya bientôt sept ans que je le fasse
jusqu'à la date raisonnable qui doit
normalement conduire à la fin de mon
mandat c'est sur ce terme de raisonnable
et l'appréciation peu varié mais je fais
mon métier présidence était
encore hier à bronzer l'octane quelques
temps auparavant enfin je vais je viens
pour des choses qui concernent la vie
nationale et je répèterai ce que je
répète partout
si je ne le fais pas est ce que l'état
se trouvera en déshérence daniel premier
ministre prémunit souhaité fait du
travail mais il est quand même très pris
par sa situation avec envie là quand on
est candidat on peut pas tout faire
parce que c'est identique je pense que
c'est difficile quand on est candidat
personne ne me suis habitué
qui a parfaitement le droit de naître
ici et je ne le critique pâques du tout
pour cela te dis simplement que mon rôle
moi est différent et comme je vais
souvent dit j'ai peur que les
téléspectateurs ne se lassent de cela je
suis pas candidat je veux garder mon
autorité le plus longtemps possible
notamment sur la scène internationale je
le suis on prend quand même quatre mois
al avance trois mois le vendre l'âme
d'un mois la voilà on arrive à atteindre
en arrive on arrive peu à peu c'est
pourquoi cette nouvelle que vous désirez
connaître vous n'attendez pas très
longtemps avant de la france votre
décisive le renouvellement de monsieur
le président votre frère robert nous a
confié récemment il était notre invité
parce qu'il vient d'écrire un livre sur
votre famille que ce sujet précisément
été abordés au cours de réunions
familiales à l'elysée qu'il faut disait
pardon mais c'est son expression il faut
y aller françois voilà ils vont mal il
n'est pas le seul dans votre famille
alors je n'ai que vous avez l'esprit de
famille est ce que les questions
un fouet l'ensemble de mes frères et
soeurs parents tout ça c'est à une
représentation très fidèle de ce qu'est
la société française bon alors ils
disent la même chose il ya pas beaucoup
d endroits
on a tous
dans ce qu'elle fait toujours vous
voulez en venir à la politique lourd et
bien je leur réponds comme vous n'en
savent pas plus fabien merci pour tous
michel briand peut-on prendre
rendez-vous alors là que vous soyez ou
non candidat candidat président de la
république pour le journal de 13h sur
antenne 2 qui suivra l'annnonce de votre
décision pour être comme lui promettre
je vais vous remercie en tout cas de
votre entière vous invite mais le
lendemain pas vous dire de toute manière
quand elle rit quelle que soit la
décision car je ne
je ne ferai pas de faille dans mon
raisonnement est le suivant quelle que
soit la décision
je viendrai en tout cas si vous voulez
mais quand ça vous garantir le jour et
l'heure non
en deux ans que la bibliothèque
nationale de france s'installera dans
ses tout nouveaux locaux une
constructions futuristes inauguré
aujourd'hui à paris par le président de
la république
un monument exemplaires selon françois
mitterrand le dernier grand chantier de
ses deux septennats l'inauguration
aujourd'hui a bien entendu servi de
tribune politique
pierre sébastien qui est de tolbiac
impossible de la manquer la bibliothèque
nationale de france
élève ses quatre tours de verre à nesle
encadrant un espace vide évoquant un
livre admis ouvert voilà pour le symbole
la tgb très grande bibliothèque ainsi
surnommé a été construite au rythme tgv
pour permettre au président de
l'inaugurer à quelques semaines de la
fin de son mandat calendrier politique
oblige sur les marches de ce nouveau
temple culturel
il y avait du beau monde un président et
deux prétendants jacques chirac est venu
avec ses lieutenants
alain juppé philippe seguin président de
l'assemblée nationale jacques toubon
ministre de la culture plus isolé mais
présent dans l'entourage présidentiel
lionel jospin aux côtés de jack lang
seul le premier ministre et candidat
edouard balladur ne pouvait être là pour
cause d'agenda
apprenez tout en matignon de moncontour
construit en moins de dix ans et le plus
monumental et le plus cher des grands
travaux présidentiels mais le public
devra attendre le printemps 97 pour
entrer à son tour dans le sanctuaire